welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
turning to Copa with Gayle King and
Anthony Mason and we're gonna begin with
this the FBI is investigating a
controversial police shooting at a
Chicago Transit station that was
captured on camera and we want to warn
you this footage may be upsetting the
witness video shows the struggle between
a man and two Chicago police officers on
Friday the man was shot twice he is now
in stable condition our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is
following the latest developments in
this fast-moving case only happened on
Friday drink a good morning what we know
good morning to you all well we know
right now this morning there are
multiple investigations into why shots
were fired an expert we spoke to says
the officer was not justified in pulling
out their gun in the first place more
than a dozen times you hear Chicago
police officers telling the man to stop
after they say he allegedly moved
between train cars and a fence that's
punishable by a fine but is not a felony
the female officer appears to use a
Taser on the men then you hear the male
officers say shoot him the video shows
the man trying to go up the escalator
and that's when you hear a second shot
his attorney says the 33 year old man
was shot in the chest and buttocks
charges against him were dropped but
investigators say they're considering
possible criminal charges against the
officers we both were extremely
concerned and have significant questions
about the incident CBS News security and
law enforcement analyst Paul violas
reviewed the nearly five minutes of cell
phone video he says this shooting never
should have happened
based on police procedure based on use
of force based on the way police are
trained it did not appear to be imminent
fear of their lives or imminent risk to
the public which would have justified
deadly physical force both officers are
on paid administrative duty during the
investigation the Chicago Police
Department issued a statement saying it
is not rushing to judgment but it is
cooperating with the independent
investigations the Fraternal Order of
Police say the
he should not be commenting until all
the facts are gathered but Mayor Lori
Lightfoot even said extremely disturbing
looking at the video officer said there
could be more video so still a lot of
questions as a reporter the charges have
been dropped
yeah now they're same possible charges
against the office it will the police
official in your piece said there are
significant questions I don't understand
being shot in the back as you're leaving
yes considering what he was accused of
doing yeah running in between trains
subway cars